qui étaient responsables de son entretien.
Il réparait les routes, raccommodait les marécages,
et faisait de l'anti-braconnage.
Et alors qu'un jour nous étions dehors ensemble,
il a croisé les empreintes d'une femelle léopard.
C'étaient d'anciennes empreintes,
mais, pour s'amuser, il a tourné et a commencé à les suivre,
et je peux vous dire, vu la vitesse
à laquelle il avançait sur ces empreintes de coussinets,
que cet homme avait l'équivalent d'un doctorat en pistage.
Si vous passiez en voiture près de Solly,
quelque part dans la réserve,
vous regardiez dans votre rétroviseur,
et vous voyiez qu'il avait arrêté sa voiture
20, 50 mètres avant,
juste au cas où vous auriez besoin d'aide.
Le seul reproche que j'ai jamais entendu à son adresse
a été quand l'un de nos clients a dit,
« Solly, vous êtes pathologiquement serviable. »
(Rires)
Quand j'ai commencé ma carrière professionnelle de guide
dans cet environnement,
Solly a été mon pisteur.
Nous avons travaillé en équipe.
Et nos tout premiers visiteurs
ont été une association caritative de votre Côte Est,
ils ont pris Solly à part, et ils lui ont dit,
« Avant même d'aller voir les lions et les léopards,
nous voulons voir où vous vivez. »
Nous les avons donc amenés chez lui.
Cette visite des philanthropes dans sa maison
a coïncidé avec une époque où la femme de Solly,
qui apprenait l'Anglais,
traversait une phase durant laquelle elle ouvrait la porte
en disant, « Bonjour, je vous aime.
Bienvenue, je vous aime. » (Rires)
Il y avait quelque chose de magnifiquement africain
pour moi, là dedans, cette petite maison,
avec un énorme cœur dedans.
Le jour où Solly m'a sauvé la vie,
il était déjà mon héro.
C'était un jour de chaleur,
et nous nous trouvions près de la rivière.
A cause de la chaleur, j'ai enlevé mes chaussures,
remonté mon pantalon,
et je me suis mis à marcher dans l'eau.
Solly est resté sur la rive.
L'eau limpide s'écoulait sur le sable,
et nous avons commencé à remonter le courant.
Quelques mètres devant nous,
il y avait un endroit où un arbre était tombé de la rive,
ses branches touchaient l'eau,
et c'était ombragé.
Si c'était un film d'horreur,
les gens dans la salle auraient commencé à dire,
« N'y va pas. N'y va pas. » (Rires)
Et bien sûr, le crocodile était dans l'ombre.
La première chose que vous remarquez, quand un crocodile vous frappe,
c'est la férocité de la morsure.
Et vlan ! Il me frappe à la jambe droite.
Il me tire. Il tourne. Je tends la main en l'air. J'arrive à saisir une branche.
Il me secoue violemment.
C'est une sensation très étrange,
que d'avoir une autre créature qui essaie de vous manger,
et il y a peu de choses qui font aussi bien la promotion du végétarisme.
(Rires)
Solly, sur la rive, voit que je suis en danger.
Il se tourne. Il commence à venir vers moi.
Le croco continue encore à me secouer.
Il revient pour me mordre une deuxième fois.
Je remarque une nappe de sang dans l'eau autour de moi,
qui est emportée par le courant.
Quand il me mord une deuxième fois, je frappe du pied.
Mon pied s'enfonce dans sa gorge. Il me recrache.
Je me tire jusque dans les branches,
et en sortant de l'eau, je regarde par dessus mon épaule.
Ma jambe est broyée sous le genou
de façon indescriptible.
L'os est fendu.
La chair est déchirée.
Je prends instantanément la décision de ne plus jamais regarder.
Pendant que je sors de l'eau,
Solly arrive à une partie plus profonde,
un canal entre nous.
Il sait, il voit l'état de ma jambe,
il sait qu'entre lui et moi
il y a un crocodile,
et je peux vous dire que cette homme ne ralentit pas une seconde pour autant.
Il entre droit dans le canal.
Il entre dans l'eau jusqu'à la poitrine.
Il m'atteint. Il m'attrape.
Je suis encore dans une position vulnérable.
Il me prend et me met sur ses épaules.
C'est l'autre caractéristique de Solly, il est effroyablement fort.
Il se retourne. Il me ramène à la rive.
Il m'allonge. Il enlève sa chemise.
Il l'enroule autour de ma jambe,
me ramasse une seconde fois,
me porte jusqu'à un véhicule,
et peut m'accompagner jusqu'aux secours médicaux.
Et je survis.
Maintenant -- (Applaudissements)
Maintenant, je ne sais pas combien vous connaissez
de personnes qui entreraient dans un profond canal,
sachant qu'il y a un crocodile dedans,
pour venir vous sauver,
mais pour Solly, c'était aussi naturel que de respirer.
Il est un exemple incroyable
de ce que j'ai pu ressentir dans toute l'Afrique.
Dans une société plus collective,
nous réalisons de l'intérieur
que notre propre bien-être est profondément lié
au bien-être d'autrui.
On partage le danger. On partage la souffrance.
On partage la joie. On partage la réussite.
On partage sa maison. On partage sa nourriture.
Ubuntu nous demande d'ouvrir nos cœurs
et de partager,
et ce que Solly m'a appris ce jour là
est l'essence de cette valeur,
son action habitée, altruiste,
à chaque instant.
Bien que ce mot soit employé à l'origine pour des personnes,
je pensais que peut-être ubuntu ne concernait que les humains.
J'ai alors rencontré cette jeune demoiselle.
Elle s'appelait Elvis.
En fait, c'est Solly qui lui a donné le nom d'Elvis,
car il disait qu'elle marchait comme si elle faisait
la danse d'Elvis le pelvis.
Elle était née avec un pelvis et des pattes arrières méchamment déformées.
Elle est arrivée depuis une réserve
située à l'est de chez nous sur sa route migratoire.
Quand je l'ai vue la première fois,
j'ai pensé qu'elle mourrait en l'espace de quelques jours.
Pourtant, les 5 années suivantes,
elle est revenue pour les mois d'hiver.
Nous étions si excités d'être dans la brousse,
et de croiser ces empreintes inhabituelles.
Elles ressemblaient à une parenthèse inversée,
et nous laissions tout tomber pour suivre ces traces,
et au détour d'un virage,
elle serait là, avec son troupeau.
Ce débordement d"émotion
venant des gens dans nos camions,
lorsqu'ils la voyaient, c'était un sentiment de parenté.
Et ça me rappelait
que même les gens qui ont grandi dans les villes
sentent un lien naturel
avec la nature et les animaux.
Pourtant, j'étais toujours stupéfié qu'elle survive.
Et puis un jour, nous sommes tombé sur eux à un petit point d'eau.
C'était une sorte de cavité dans le sol.
J'observais la matriarche boire,
et soudain elle s'est retournée, dans ce beau ralenti propre aux éléphants,
ça ressemble à un bras en mouvement,
et elle a commencé à remonter la berge.
Le reste du troupeau a commencé à la suivre.
Et j'ai regardé la jeune Elvis
commencer à se motiver pour grimper la pente.
Elle avait visiblement -- elle a tendu ses oreilles en avant,
elle a fait une tentative, et à mi-hauteur,
ses pattes ont cédé, et elle retombée en arrière.
Elle a essayé une deuxième fois,
et à nouveau, à mi-hauteur, elle est retombée en arrière.
A la troisième tentative,
une chose incroyable s'est produite.
A mi-hauteur de la berge,
un jeune éléphant adolescent est venu derrière elle,
il l'a soutenue de sa trompe,
et il a commencé à la pousser vers le haut de la berge.
Et il m'est venu à l'esprit
que le reste du troupeau
veillait en réalité sur cette jeune éléphante.
Le jour suivant, j'ai observé de nouveau
la matriarche casser une branche
pour la mettre dans sa bouche,
puis en casser une deuxième,
et la laisser tomber par terre.
Et tous ceux qui guidaient les gens dans cette zone
sont tombés d'accord pour dire que
ce troupeau se déplaçait plus lentement
pour s'adapter à cette éléphante.
Ce qu'Elvis et le troupeau m'ont appris
m'a poussé à étendre ma définition d'ubuntu,
et je pense que dans la cathédrale de la nature sauvage,
les plus belles parts de nous-mêmes
nous sont révélées.
Ce n'est pas uniquement au travers d'autres personnes
que nous pouvons ressentir notre humanité,
mais également au travers de toutes les créatures qui vivent sur cette planète.
Si l'Afrique a un don à offrir,
c'est celui d'une société plus collective.
Et s'il est vrai qu'ubuntu est une idée africaine,
je vois l'essence de cette valeur
être recréée ici.
Merci.
(Aplaudissements)
Pat Mitchell : Boyd,
nous savons que vous connaissiez le Président Mandela
depuis la petite enfance,
que vous avez entendu la nouvelle comme nous tous aujourd'hui,
que vous êtes profondément bouleversé,
et que vous savez la perte tragique que cela représente pour le monde.
Mais je me demandais si vous voudriez
nous en dire quelques mots supplémentaires,
car nous savons que vous avez appris la nouvelle
juste avant de venir faire cette conférence.
Boyd Varty : Eh bien merci, Pat.
Je suis heureux, car je pense qu'il était temps pour lui de s'éteindre.
Il souffrait.
Bien sûr, ce sont des sentiments partagés.
Mais je pense à tellement de moments,
comme la fois où il est allé à l'émission d'Oprah Winfrey,
et lui a demandé quel était le thème de l'émission.
(Rires)
Et elle a dit, genre, « Eh bien, ce sera à propos de vous. »
Je veux dire, c'est d'une incroyable humilité.
(Rires)
Il était le père de notre nation,
et nous avons du chemin à faire en Afrique du Sud.
Tout ça, ils appelaient ça la magie de Madiba.
Vous savez, à chaque fois qu'il allait à un match de rugby, on gagnait.
Partout où il allait, les choses se passaient bien.
Mais je pense que cette magie sera avec nous,
et l'important est de porter en nous
ce pour quoi il s'est battu.
C'est ce que je vais essayer de faire,
et ce que des gens dans toute l'Afrique du Sud essayent de faire.
PM : Et c'est ce que vous avez fait aujourd'hui. BV : Oh, merci.
PM : Merci. BV : Merci. Merci beaucoup.
(Aplaudissements)